welcome back so today i'm really excited to
tell you about a new kind of emerging field
of machine learning where we're essentially
learning coordinate systems and dynamics
at the same time for complex systems so especially
i'm going to talk about deep learning to discover
coordinate systems where you can get simple or
parsimonious representations of the dynamics in
those coordinates okay so in particular i'm going
to mostly be talking about autoencoder networks
so here you might have some high dimensional
state x that describes your system maybe this
is a video uh you're you're recording your
system and you're trying to learn the dynamics
uh maybe of a pendulum swinging or of you know
some phenomena you're trying to observe and with
deep learning we're going to essentially discover
a coordinate embedding phi and a decoder psi
so that you can map into a latent space z that has
kind of the minimal essential information that you
need to describe your system and specifically
we're going to try to learn these auto encoder
networks so that we can represent the dynamics
in that latent space very efficiently or simply
okay so in this latent space z again that's
like the minimal description of your system
uh through this autoencoder network we're looking
for a dynamical system z dot equals f of z where f
is as simple as possible and so this is really an
important dual problem so on the one hand you have
uh the coordinate system discovery the the fee and
psi coordinates and on the other hand you have the
dynamical systems discovery we're trying to learn
this efficient model f that accurately describes
how this system evolves in time so i'm going to
walk you through a number of key architectures
for how you can do this with deep learning uh what
restrictions we can put on f and phi and psi and
also tie this a little bit to kind of the history
of coordinate discovery and dynamical systems
okay good and i think this is a good example
kind of motivating what we would like to do
so maybe we have a video of some complex system
in this case this is just a pendulum in my lab
and what you would like to be able to do is from
this you know movie or this you know megapixel
image that's evolving in time you would like
to be able to discover automatically without
a human expert in the loop that there is a
key variable theta that describes the system
the kind of minimal descriptive variable for
the motion of this pendulum is the angle theta
and you'd also like to just discover that
the dynamical system governing the motion
of this pendulum the evolution of theta is
given by a simple differential equation here
so that's kind of at a very high
level what we'd like to be able to do
my colleague nathan kutz calls this gopro physics
sometimes so you'd like to be able to have you
know just a movie watching the world learning the
physics learning you know how clouds are evolving
learning how pendulums swing things like that
learning how balls drop according to f equals ma
okay so that's kind of what we want to do but this
is a difficult task to learn these coordinates and
to learn these dynamics good and so you know i'm
going to zoom out a little bit and talk about
just kind of general challenges we have when
we model dynamical systems x dot equals f of x
again most of the world around us is dynamic
it's evolving in time and in space whether you're
thinking about a fluid flow or an autonomous
vehicle the state of your brain you know
your collection of neurons a weather system or a
disease model these are all dynamical systems that
change in time according to some rules
on the right hand side some physics f x
and so the big challenges that we have one of them
is often we don't know this model f of x we don't
have a good model for the dynamics so we need
to discover that model in the case of the brain
that's a good example non-linearity is another key
challenge so even a small amount of non-linearity
really hampers our ability to simulate
estimate predict and control these systems
in the real world from limited measurements
and again this is somewhere where finding
good coordinate transformations can make a big
difference in simplifying nonlinear dynamics
and the third challenge we very very frequently
face in the real world is high dimensionality
times you know we do have this camera this movie
of a very high dimensional uh pixel space or we
have a simulation or a measurement of a fluid
flow with you know thousands or millions of
degrees of freedom and so we want to essentially
leverage the fact that patterns exist in that data
to find those low dimensional representations
those kind of autoencoder coordinates i showed you
so that we can discover the dynamics and maybe
even handle some of the the non-linearity
okay so that's kind of a very high level overview
of some of the things we want to do with these
autoencoder networks okay uh and again you know
i'm going to use the example of fluids it's one
of my favorite examples we know that even in very
very high dimensional systems like weather systems
or you know more classical fluid flows even though
we would require hundreds of thousands millions or
billions of degrees of freedom to represent these
in a computer or with our satellite images we know
that there are low dimensional patterns and a few
degrees of freedom that matter i really like this
video here that shows kind of this low dimensional
pattern in this very high dimensional system
and so i'm going to motivate
these deep autoencoder networks
more classically through the singular value
decomposition okay so this goes by many many names
in different fields singular value decomposition
principal components analysis proper orthogonal
decomposition but if you have some complex system
that you believe has low dimensional patterns
you can essentially compute the singular
value decomposition of a data matrix
and you can decompose this this movie into a
linear combination of a very small number of
modes or kind of eigen states that uh capture
most of the energy or variance of this system
okay and the way i like to think about this
this is a data-driven generalization of the
fourier transform this is essentially a fourier
transform that's tailored to this very specific
problem you're looking at the specific data that
you've collected now in the uh lens of modern
kind of neural networks you can look at the uh
the svd or the principal components analysis
as a shallow linear auto encoder network where
you have a high dimensional state x that might
be my whole flow field stacked into a column
vector and what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to find some latent representation some minimal
set of variables z so that if i compress down to
z i can lift back up to the original state
and recover as much information about that
high dimensional state as possible so this is
literally the u and the v matrices from the svd
and this latent space z here would be the
amplitudes of these these modes these pod modes
now in practice i would not recommend
actually using a neural network to
compute the svd it's way more efficient to to
compute it using a qr factorization or some
kind of classical numerical linear algebra
technique but as a as an abstraction we
can think of the svd as a very very simple
neural network and so what we're going to do
is generalize this linear coordinate in betting
and again this is a coordinate system to represent
your dynamics we're going to generalize this
coordinate system by making it now a deep neural
network so instead of one latent space layer now
we're going to have many many hidden layers for
the encoder many hidden layers for the decoder and
our activation units our nodes are going to have
non-linear activation functions and so what this
allows us to do is instead of learning a linear
subspace where our data is efficiently represented
now we're able to learn a non-linear manifold
parameterized by these coordinate z where our data
is efficiently represented and often that means we
can get a massive reduction in degrees of freedom
needed to describe this latent space z good and
So this is kind of what this abstract autoencoder network
is trying to represent
usually I have many many hidden layers in 'Phi' and
in 'Psi' and I have non-linear activation functions
so the 'z' parameterizes a manifold.
Good, and we can learn these essentially
by constructing this architecture
in Tensorflow or Pytorch or whatever neural
network training framework you like and
essentially cooking up a loss function
so that we want the output minus the input to
have the smallest error possible given that we've
choked down the information to maybe three
latent variables in 'z'. So you fix the number
of latent variables you fix the architecture
and you train this so that it minimizes the
error between the output and the input and it
learns then the latent features of that input.
And so, like i mentioned earlier, what we're going
to do now is we're going to be training these
autoencoder networks not just to represent the
data in 'x' efficiently but also to be able to
predict how the dynamics and that latent space
evolves accurately and efficiently forward intime.
So now we're going to be learning not just
the encoder and the decoder but we're going to
be learning a representation of the dynamical
system 'f' that evolves the system forward in time.
And this is becoming a big deal in the machine
learning community because now we're able to
start understanding the physics of how our
movies or our high dimensional inputs are evolvingin time.
I like to give this example. I think
this is an extremely motivating example
where what you have here is this great
visualization of the geocentric view of the solar
system. So the blue dot is Earth, the yellow dot is
the sun and the red dots are the other planets in
the solar system. If we have kind of a naive
coordinate system where the Earth is at the center
of the solar system then you see that you actually
get extremely complex dynamics. These are
really complicated circles on circles and
there's no obvious simple law that describes the
motion of all of these bodies in this coordinate
system. But if we change our coordinates, so now we
put the sun at the center of the solar system
and every other planet is going around the sun
now this becomes a much much simpler dynamical
system and this is amenable to discovering the
basic laws of physics 'F=ma' and Kepler's laws
of motion. So i think that this is an
extremely motivating example that shows that
when you have the right coordinate system you
have some hope of learning a dynamical system 'f' that's
simple. I could try to learn a dynamical system
that describes this evolution here but that
differential equation is going to be much more
complicated harder to interpret and understand
and generalize so getting the right coordinate
systems is often essential to learning the right
dynamics. And that's been born true over and over
throughout the history of physics. Good, so
that's what we're trying to do here we're going
to learn the coordinate system that simplifies
the dynamics. Now I'm going to walk you through
a few examples of how we've been doing this and
what some of the challenges and opportunities are.
So one of my favorite networks here is one
that was developed by Kathleen Champion
when she was a PhD student with Nathan and me and
this is essentially combining SINDy, or the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics, to learn
a dynamical system in the latent space of an
autoencoder and i think this is a really clever
network design so essentially what kathleen is
doing is she's learning these encoder and decoder
networks these are big deep neural networks
and there's additional loss functions
that we use in our neural network training
so that the dynamics in z are essentially a sparse
linear combination of candidate non-linearities in
a library so we basically build this big library
of the possible terms that could describe the
dynamics in z and then we essentially try to find
the fewest the sparses combination of those terms
that describe z1.z2.z3 dot in the latent space
and so to do this kathleen had to introduce a
number of extra loss functions to make this the
cindy auto encoder converge to the right solution
essentially um there's the original reconstruction
loss if you just remove the dynamics in the middle
you still want your auto encoder to faithfully
capture your data to find a good latent space
but then we have these additional cindy losses and
the cindy regularization so the l1 term at the end
tries to make this set of column vectors as
sparse as possible so we have as few terms in
the dynamics as possible that makes it so that our
dynamical system is interpretable and simple it's
more like f equals m a than some big complicated
expression and then essentially these additional
two loss functions take different parts of
this network and make sure that if i compute
x dot here it's the same as if i took z dot
here and mapped it out and things like that
so essentially you can compute chain rules
on different sub networks and make sure that
the dynamics the time derivatives across those
different pieces of the network are consistent
that essentially makes sure that you don't get
into weird issues where you just try to shrink the
z as small as possible which would in principle
also make c small so this is a really cool network
that kathleen developed she was able to learn
lots of very very sparse parsimonious dynamical
systems in these latent spaces for complex
systems and one of her systems was actually
a movie of a pendulum a synthetic movie of
a pendulum okay so uh this is a really nice
way to learn kind of those dynamics and uh and
coordinates but what if we want to do more than
just learn a sparse non-linear model what if we
actually want to try to find a coordinate system
that actually linearizes our dynamics so we know
from kupeman operator theory that this is often
possible now there's lots of caveats but there
are often these special coordinate systems fee
that if i take my original dynamics and i map it
into you know the latent space through z i might
even be able to expect a linear dynamical system
z dot equals l of z now why would i want this
linear dynamics are kind of you know generically
solvable with textbook methods we can get optimal
linear estimators and controllers with you know
one line of matlab or python so anytime we can
make our system linear we gain a tremendous amount
uh in doing so now the big big big caveat here
is that this puts a tremendous amount of uh
strain on the encoder and decoder networks
so finding a coordinate system like in the cindy
auto encoder where we have sparse dynamics that's
not that bad for the coordinate system to do we
can find a coordinate system where there's a few
sparse non-linear terms this is related to
normal forms from dynamical systems theory
but if we want to actually remove all of
those nonlinear terms and make the system
truly linear that's a much much uh stronger set
of constraints that we're putting on this this
encoder and decoder network so generally speaking
these are much harder to train much more expensive
and these might be much nastier functions fee
to get these linear dynamics but the good thing
is just like most of neural network
training this is a very big expensive
offline training cost but once you've found
these coordinate systems you can use them forever
online in a very fast and efficient way
you can do optimal estimation and control
in this latent space once you've put
in the upfront cost of learning fee
now again this could be a deep neural network with
non-linear activation functions but it could also
be a shallow neural network with linear activation
functions in which case this kind of linear
dynamics auto encoder would represent the dynamic
mode decomposition okay so if if phi and psi were
shallow with linear activation units this would
essentially encode the dynamic mode decomposition
so dmd has been used at length in fluid
mechanics and many other fields to get
linear representations of nonlinear
systems like these periodic fluid flows
and essentially dmd is finding some kind of a
linear regression model on those svd coordinates
i talked about earlier okay and there's
another cool paper here that connects it to
coupeman operator theory so if you take that
idea of the dynamic mode decomposition which
is an extremely popular useful kind of general
purpose linear modeling technique and you take
this neural network representation and you make
those encoders and decoders deep neural networks
with nonlinear activation functions what we're
essentially doing is learning a non-linear analog
of the dynamic mode decomposition we're learning
a nonlinear coordinate system that'll take an
original non-linear system and make it look
linear and so that's exactly what many many
groups in the community have done in the last
few years so i'm showing you work by bethany lush
who was a postdoc with nathan kutzen myself
this is her deep koopman auto encoder where
she takes her input and essentially through
some some hidden layers learns a coordinate
system and encoder where she can get linear
dynamical systems again she looked at systems
like like a pendulum or flow past a cylinder
where there is a continuous eigenvalue spectrum
so she needed to kind of add a few innovations to
this network to parametrize these linear dynamics
by the frequency of the system there have been
many many other groups that have developed similar
deep kootman autoencoder networks that essentially
learn these coordinates where your dynamics can be
simply or linearly represented and i want
to point out that those different approaches
to these kind of koopman networks or these
non-linear analogs of dynamic mode decomposition
come in many shapes and sizes and we talk
about this in a recent review paper we wrote
on the coupeman operator theory this is kind of
a beast of a paper it's about 100 pages and it's
all about how you find these coordinate systems
with neural networks and with other approaches
and there's kind of two big philosophies that
the community has arrived at one of them is the
the kind of constrictive autoencoder that
i showed you before where you have a high
dimensional state you choke it down to a lower
dimensional latent space where you can model
the dynamics linearly and then you can you know
kind of decode that latent space to your original
state x but what many people in the community
have also done is take your your system state
and actually lift it to a higher dimensional
latency variable z so you can take you know
even if you have a high dimensional state x you
can lift it to an even higher dimensional state
try to model the evolution in that higher
dimensional state with linear dynamics given
by this matrix k and then you can always map
back down to x and these are two very very
different philosophies of how you can get
embeddings that give you linear representations
of your dynamics now i'll point out um this
bottom approach here is actually much you know
this is reminiscent of lots of things that
people do in machine learning already like
pooling and lifting kernel methods often if
you operate in a very high dimensional space
non-linear processes can look more linear so
this is very consistent with you know existing
machine learning literature but i will point out
oftentimes these kind of constrictive autoencoders
are more consistent with our physical intuition
that even in these very high dimensional systems
there might be a few dominant coherent
structures or patterns that we really care about
and we want to find out how those behave
and evolve linearly so these constrictive
autoencoders might be more interpretable you might
be able to tease out relationships when you are
working in a low dimensional latent space
z both are valid approaches and i just
wanted to point out that you know lots of
methods explore both of these architectures
and since i'm already here talking about
this koopman review paper i'll just kind of
give a couple of teasers there's lots
and lots of stuff we talk about here
so the basic idea of koopman is that if you
have some original dynamical system like this
duffing oscillator with three fixed points you
can essentially find new coordinate systems or
coordinate transformations where you expand
the region of linear validity you kind of
expand where linearization is valid through a
nonlinear coordinate system so here for example
i might take my local linearization around
this third fixed point and i might find a
local coordinate system where all of the dynamics
in this p pink region are approximately linear
another perspective of these systems there are
global coordinates that appear linear like the the
hamiltonian energy of this uh duffing oscillator
so this this phase portrait is given by a particle
in this potential well here this double well
potential and the actual energy level of the
particle is itself one of these eigenfunctions
it's a hamiltonian that behaves linearly in time
the time derivative of the hamiltonian is zero
times the hamiltonian that's linear dynamics
and this fourth perspective here i think
is really cool um and we're still exploring
this you can also rescale space and time so that
non-linear oscillators like this oscillator here
appear to be more like linear oscillators like
you know just sine and cosine pairs and that
uh is something that henning henning lang has
recently looked into is essentially building
deep neural networks that can rescale kind of time
and space to make your non-linear oscillators look
like a single linear oscillator and in very
complex examples like this shear layer fluid flow
he's been able to find really really simple low
dimensional representations that very accurately
represent this non-linear oscillator system okay
a couple of other examples before i conclude
so those deep koopman neural networks i was
telling you about for ordinary differential
equations craig gin and bethany lush recently
extended that to partial differential equations
so we know that even for spatial temporal evolving
systems there are often coordinate systems
that will make them look approximately
linear so for example in the nonlinear
burgers equation which describes the evolution of
uh and formation of shock waves in fluid systems
there is the classic coal hop transformation that
transforms the nonlinear burgers equation into the
linear heat equation and with our koopman network
applied to partial differential equations we can
essentially learn that linearizing transform in
an automated way without knowing any kind of first
principles physics or having even having access of
the governing equations so just from data we can
learn these linearizing transforms in in pdes we
also have a method this is with craig gin and dan
shea essentially to find these deep embeddings to
discover non-linear analogs of green's functions
and green's functions are very very useful
for linear boundary value problems in partial
differential equations and essentially what we can
do is through a very similar nonlinear autoencoder
network we can learn these non-linear analogs
of green's functions which would have lots of
applications and like non-linear beam theory or
you know aircraft wings that can deform massively
past where the linear approximation is valid okay
so i want to just kind of tie this up and conclude
here so we've talked about how there is this joint
problem of learning coordinates and dynamics this
is uh one of the most exciting areas of machine
learning research for physics informed machine
learning or for physics discovery with machine
learning where oftentimes you know if i don't know
what the right coordinate system is to measure
my system maybe i'm looking at the brain or
you know the climate system or a disease system i
don't know what the right coordinate system is to
get a simple law you know like f equals m a or e
equals m c squared and so we can set up this dual
optimization problem where we're simultaneously
trying to learn the coordinate embedding fee
to find a latent space z where the dynamics
in that latent space are as simple as possible
i've shown you two examples one is where f is
sparse and non-linear using our cindy approach
another perspective is where you try to find
a coordinate embedding where f is actually
linear this is a matrix and both of those are you
know getting widely explored in the literature
lots and lots of networks are being developed to
learn those embeddings for lots of complex systems
so i encourage you to try it out and to think
of what other constraints you might put on f
and fee and psi for example maybe you have
symmetries in your system and you want
these embeddings to respect those symmetries or
you have some conservation law that you know is
going to be satisfied like conservation of
momentum or energy you know colleagues are
already building these networks that have those
baked in and so there's tons of opportunity to
put partially known physics into your
system and to learn entirely new system
system physics that we didn't know
before all right thank you very much